e você sabe qual é o tamanho da vida que
você quer viver
e eu só fiz essa pergunta para mim
quando eu já tinha mais de 40 anos e
empreendido quatro empresas
e em 2006 eu decidi abrir uma escola
e eu estava Incomodada com a falta de
formação para profissionais das áreas
criativas
é uma escola de Economia criativa
e como a formação contemporânea
E aí Déia
quem nasceu em junho e Setembro abrimos
as portas
o sucesso desde a primeira aula de
alunos de todo o Brasil e logo de outros
países também
e a gente colocou economia criativa no
mapa do Brasil Escola São Paulo
em qual os números parecer um Crysis 3
mil alunos por ano
há 13 anos faturar vamos quatro vezes o
previsto no início do projeto
e eu fui badalada ganhei prêmios
profissionais incríveis pediam para
trabalhar com a gente e os nossos alunos
eram a moçada mais linda do mundo
há alguns anos se passaram nesse ritmo
de crescimento e o que ninguém sabia que
quando eu colocava a cabeça no
travesseiro
e eu não conseguia dormir
e eu só pensava em todos os desafios que
eu ia ter que
se enfrentar no dia seguinte
e eu virei uma administradora de prédios
eu tive que passar a exercer nos
primeiros anos da escola é atividades
que não eram do meu expertise tampouco a
razão pela qual eu tinha aberto a escola
que era criar cursos e ficar próxima de
alunos e professores não eu tinha que
fazer de tudo
eu não ia dar para continuar crescendo
no dia seguinte ia ser difícil
o quanto mais escola crescia mais ou
menos sociável do meu propósito
e eu fui iludindo com a ideia de crescer
crescer crescer
a competir g15 tipo incentivar as
equipes para elas desempenhar o melhor
papel a gente sempre precisava ter mais
visibilidade nunca era o suficiente
é a vida mudou radicalmente naquele
período só que não mudou para melhor
e a empresa crescia e Meu bem está no
aumentava nada
e eu pensei que alguma coisa não estava
certa
Oi mas como é o preço do crescimento
e eu só sabia que eu queria
eu voltar para um lugar que eu não
conhecia mas
é mas eu me lembrava aqui um direitinho
existido a minha vida era vamos dizer
que ela era estava assim no modelo ideal
para uma capa de revistas ou porque se
ensina em algumas escolas de negócios
bizness eu mas para mim ainda faltava
deitar na cama e dormir tranquila
e o tempo
Essa é uma das coisas mais preciosas que
a gente tem na vida e para ganhar
dinheiro a gente usa essa Preciosidade a
gente gasta o nosso tempo para se
dedicar dinheiro e eu sempre falo para
os meus clientes
a press tensão no como você ganha E como
você gasta o seu dinheiro Tudo bem se
você quiser muito dinheiro Tudo bem não
tem problema
é a questão é ele te distanciado o seu
eu
se você entender Qual é a sua história
e É como se eu fosse uma chef de cozinha
que ao abrir o restaurante dos sonhos
descobrisse que tinha que passar o dia
inteiro na caixa
e é começou a surgir muitas dúvidas
alguma coisa não estava certa eu tinha
passado usar uma régua de crescimento
que não era minha
e eu queria voltar para o 3º ano da
escola
o cabo no terceiro ano mas eu não soube
para ele
é mas porque é que eu não porque é que
eu não soube parar na hora certa porque
eu não sabia qual era o tamanho da vida
que eu queria viver
e o crescimento
o EA competitividade leva uma aceleração
e não é possível viver assim
E ontem eu sentei no computador
eu publiquei uma carta
Ah entendi cresci e não gostei
e essa carta deu muita reprodução
as pessoas do mundo todo me escreviam
dizendo que era a primeira vez que
algumas que elas tinham ouvido falar
se alguém falar que o empreendedor dessa
forma que tudo que eles aprendiam no dia
a dia era criança cresça você tem que
competir você pode chegar lá longe
e não importa se você sofre me importa
se você chora não importa se você não
aguenta mais não importa se você não
dorme não importa se você tiver crises
de pânico nada importa porque esse é o
preço do crescimento e tá correto você
lá na frente você vai ganhar um prêmio
e eu fui pensando aqui uma boa vida para
mim era incluia tempo deveria incluir
tempo para eu exercer a minha
vulnerabilidade tempo para eu
a atender as solicitações repentinas de
alunos de amigos tempo para
Se eu andar caminhar pensar estudar
a cozinhar e até pro te tempo para não
fazer nada
Oi e aí eu comecei a me abrir para
escutar outras vozes eu até então eu
estava muito envolvida com vozes que
falavam aquele blá-blá-blá do
crescimento
o modelo cartesiano dispensar eu abri a
minha mente para ouvir outras vozes de
pessoas que têm um pensamento sistêmico
um pensamento holístico
Oi e eu comecei a perceber coisas
incríveis eu fui lendo é
e autores
tô assistindo toques de pessoas que
falavam que de crescer possível
o que você que a gente deve tomar
cuidado com os limites do crescimento
que é possível
é melhor ser mais simples
Quem é E aí começou a fase mais difícil
para mim porque eu percebi que eu tinha
que mudar as coisas o jeito que eu tinha
construído
é a minha empresa e o meu modo de viver
por consequência daquela empresa
Oi e aí eu sentei e falei eu vou fazer
uma lista do que é que eu tenho na minha
vida aqui em provoca bem-estar e eu
criei uma tabela com três colunas que eu
denominei de marido elas vezes é chamada
de Bela deve também
é a primeira coluna eu coloco o que eu
preciso para manter o meu bem-estar
e na segunda coluna
com o tempo a média do ano né de tempo
que eu preciso para me dedicar aquela
primeira coluna na terceira coluna o
custo de cada uma daquelas atividades
e vocês vem que ali por exemplo tem um
pouco alguns minutos só para alguns dos
itens é porque alguns assuntos moradia
alimentação saúde mobilidade família
amigos comunicação lazer estudos
responsabilidade social sono e banho
cada um cria sua tabela com seus itens
cada um deles alguns algumas alguns
deles como médicos por exemplo eu é um
tempo que o uma duas três vezes por ano
eu sou um essas horas e divido por 365
dias eu chego então alguns itens dão dez
minutos por dia 31 e 22 3:30 quando eu
terminei de fazer essa tabela eu quero
ser Bic eu tinha 20 horas por dia
comprometidas com aquilo que me causava
bem-estar xinga não podia ter
e eu trabalhava 17 18 horas por dia mas
não como estava me corrompendo E aí
quando eu fui levantar o custos Eu
também me surpreendi porque eu percebi
que ao mesmo tempo eu precisava de menos
dinheiro do que eu achava para viver uma
boa vida
é porque eu me satisfazendo com aquelas
itens A primeira coluna eu não precisava
de muito mais então as quatro horas
talvez fossem possíveis E aí eu penso
mas isso eu preciso em algum período da
minha vida desde cá a um projeto ou
algum trabalho 6 ou 8 horas o que que eu
faço eu vou até a minha tabela e negocia
comigo mesma repente eu tenho ali 8
horas para sono e banho de repente agora
vou durante dois meses dois três meses
eu vou dormir uma hora menos eu não vou
assistir filmes eu não vou viajar e ali
eu ganhei duas três quatro horas dali
três meses eu volto pra tabela de novo e
substitua aqueles itens que eu subtrair
por outros fazendo com que não fique
pesado para mim eu ficar por exemplo
muito tempo sem viajar sem dormir
direito
bom e sem assistir filmes que são uma
fonte de informação para mim e dessa
forma eu fui descobrindo que eu consigo
manter uma régua média de bem-estar por
que que eu fazia antes eu ficava um ano
dois eu falava eu não vou fazer isso nem
isso no início a dedicar tanto as horas
e no decorrer desses desses desse um ano
dois anos que você abole alguma coisa da
sua da sua rotina você pode adoecer Você
pode ter dores no corpo você pode ter
medos Você pode passar a ter viver um
stress sua vida você vai conseguir
render menos e você vai gastar mais
dinheiro com médicos
e é eu fiz essa tabela com algumas
pessoas que disseram que quanto mais
elas trabalharam mais dinheiro elas
precisa comprar para viver
Oi e aí eu falei bom eu preciso
conversar comigo
e eu tenho que simplificar eu tenho que
tirar tudo que me ocupa a mais do que
essas quatro poucas mais horas à mais eu
preciso conversar comigo eu acredito que
a sustentabilidade que eu desejo para
mim e para o mundo ela tem que começar
com o meu modo de viver e aí eu troquei
meu carro para uma bicicleta eu fui
morar numa casa meia hora me recolhi
abrir um espaço interno comecei a me ver
e ver o outro
e eu fui
e conhecendo esses esses pensamentos
dessas pessoas comum kannemann Daniel
kahneman que é um Nobel de Economia
satish kumar fundador da Schumacher
College André Lara Resende um economista
brasileiro Kate pickett que Deus que
nível econômico estão deixando fomos
lendo eles e aprendendo tudo que eles
tinham para nos dizer com uma pequena
equipe da escola que se resolveu apoiar
a minha ideia que concordou comigo Nós
nos reunimos todos os dias de manhã na
minha casa a gente começava o dia
estudando esses autores maravilhosos
meditando fazendo um chá dali a gente
traçava as metas do dia
o e menos de seis meses nós conseguimos
de crescer a escola São Paulo
é de dois prédios com salas de aulas
para cursos virtuais
é de 52 funcionários para 0
eu nunca tinha sido tão ágil
bom e simples e leve realizar um projeto
tão ambicioso como aquele
um bom processo de cura
é o tempo que eu ganhei eu pude começar
a me dedicar para o com causas que eu
acredito como as causas de mudanças
climáticas com fridays for Future e com
a causa dos refugiados Eu trabalho com a
ONU
bom e depois quando eu penso nessa
história toda que eu vivi me vem em
mente aquela história do pescador
pescador morava numa praia ele tinha um
pequeno bar e uma canoa
é um já chegou um rico empresário que
sabe ali de férias foi comprar uma
cerveja e falou para ele Pô cara eu vou
te ensinar ficar rico olhou em volta
aquele bares Onde estás cair pois quando
ele falou como ele se chama alguém para
trabalhar com você no seu bar você vai
conseguir vender mais bebidas vai ganhar
mais dinheiro e a comprar mais uma canoa
Oi e o pescador disso E aí
E ele fala e aí você vai pescar mais
peixes vai ganhar mais dinheiro e compra
o trabalho e daí e daí você compra mais
Canoas abre mais vários mais Canoas mais
bares pescado outro lado olhou para o
outro
e olhou pro barzinho dele olhou para o
empresário e falando para que empresário
falou porque daí você vai ficar rico e
vem passar as férias aqui no lugar lindo
como eu
E qual é o tamanho da vida que você quer
viver
Olá seja do seu tamanho
bom obrigada tá